[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
زوايا مثلث السعاده عند الانسان العربي
قديما وحديثا المطر والربيع والفقع فالمطر
يطلع الربيع وتتابعه يطلع الفقع ولقط
الفقع رياضه محببه لدى الانسان العربي فهو
رياض هو فراسه وتطبب قال النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم الكماه من المن وماؤها شفاء
للعين والفجع انواع ومن اهمها ثلاثه
الزبيدي وهو الفقعه الابيض الذي يطلع على
وجه الارض الخلاسي وهو الفجع الحمر الذي
يطلع على جنبات الاوديه والشعاب الجباه
وهو الفقع الاشهب الذي يظهر على الارض
اللينه وسهله ومن الطبيعي ان الانسان
العربي يشتهي لقطه الفقع واكله ليش لانه
يدل على الخيريه واهم على شرخ الشباب
المشتهى خلف ذاكره بقلبي ومضى اطيب عيش
المرء في شبابه فان تولى فه
مزدره
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والفقع نوع من الفطر ينتج بتفاعل بكتيريا
بين شجره الرقروق ونبته ارجه وعنصر
كيميائي وفره البرق ولهذا العرب يسمونه
بنبت الرعد والعامه يقولون لتجانس الطباع
بين شخصين الفقع بجنب ارده
[موسيقى]